[Musique]
coût
on
[Musique]
ans
le temple de la prospérité éternelle
s'apprête à fêter sa 121e nouvelle année
ces jeunes élèves préparent la cérémonie
il brûle ses longs bâtons d'encens
afin d'honorer les divinités dans la
cour intérieure guidés par leurs maîtres
ces apprentis se recueille en guise de
respect avant la danse des dieux plié
avant la danse enfin pour que tout se
passe bien
normalement on fait la ferme au niveau 6
pour le matériel pour être en confiance
avec ce qu'on va faire
au son du tambour et des cymbales le
lion symbole de force de courage et de
sagesse comment ça danse l'animal est
incarnée par deux danseurs l'un a ni le
corps et la queue tandis que l'autre
contrôler sa terre le costaud et foires
arrière pour porter ceux qui sont devant
et les plus agiles et plus fin ah ils
font avant parce qu'ils seront libres
pour sauter c'est important pour toi de
perpétuer cette tradition
oui beaucoup ça me tient à coeur et
pourquoi parce que c'est la tradition
chinoise et du beau considère comme un
chinois
des gestes précis et coordonnées qui
auront nécessité des années
l'entrainement au rythme assourdissant
de la musique
le danseur caché sous la tête du lion
exécute sa chorégraphe
il ya des bases et après justement
chaque danseur peut improviser son style
de danse et c'est justement c'est que
j'aime la danse du lion ce que chacun
d'entre nous peuvent à travers l'union
faire ressortir sa personnalité sa façon
de danser
si les pas du tout l'impression de
devenir quelqu'un d'autre c'est ce que
tu dis ouais je sors un peu comme si les
terrains presque adepte des et du coup
quand je sors du temps quand je remets
mes habits de ville
quand je prépare à l'école pour célébrer
cette nouvelle année la troupe de
l'association ti ligne seront dans un
commerce à la montagne les lions danse à
l'extérieur avant d'arpenter les allées
du magasin un rite ancestral porteurs de
chance et de prospérité
la danse du lion pour les chinois c'est
l'animal des animaux mythiques de
l'histoire de la chine le lion sert à
chasser le mauvais esprit et arpenter la
chance le bonheur au lieu il est le
gardien
il est le gardien des portes dont en
faisant la danse du lion
on enlève tout ce qui était pas
bénéfique l'année
l'année dernière et pour que la nouvelle
année se passe correctement les
battements ralentissent les lions se
posent sur le sol là dedans se termine
les propriétaires du magasin font
exploser des pétards qui selon la
coutume éloigneront les mauvais esprits
de ce don
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]